puede parecer sorprendente pero las
redes sociales son una de las nuevas
armas de los indígenas brasileños para
luchar por sus derechos y llegar a la
gente los jóvenes han está utilizando
una nueva herramienta de resistencia que
es internet y las redes sociales es una
herramienta que puede marcar una gran
diferencia en la lucha del movimiento
indígena por ejemplo es una forma de
llegar a otras personas para que nos
ayuden más sus demandas son claras
quieren luchar por la educación en la
sanidad y la protección de las tierras
para los pueblos originarios de brasil
que si el país con mayor concentración
de población indígena en aislamiento de
toda sudamérica nuestros territorios se
están secando nuestros pueblos se están
muriendo por todo lo que ha estado
pasando la minería el agronegocio que
han llegado a un nivel en el que el
planeta ya no puede soportarlo nosotros
no podemos soportarlo desde la llegada
del ultraderechista ya ir bolsonaro al
poder los pueblos indígenas se han
manifestado repetidamente en su contra
en contra de sus políticas y buscando
impedir la aprobación de un proyecto ley
que pretende legalizar la minería ilegal
en reservas indígenas
desde su campaña bolsonaro dijo que no
iba a dejar ni un centímetro de la
tierra de marcada para los pueblos
indígenas así que desde el inicio de su
campaña nos declaró la guerra
jugar un poco como se conoce a la
minería ilegal está causando graves
problemas entre las comunidades
indígenas ya que los que están metidos
en el negocio reparten armas a grupos
rivales para que se maten entre ellos y
quedarse con el control de la tierra
[Aplausos]